[Music]
thought I was done doing cosplay
tutorials ah Preposterous it's a
it's the last one it's not that I
haven't been cosplaying it's just that I
haven't felt like filming the process
for building them in a bit but I got my
cosplay partner in crime Jacob in town
to hang out in person for the first time
ever
this script was written in 2022. and our
buddy Diego to tag along as well when we
went to Denver Comic-Con Fan Expo pop
culture whatever the hell they're
calling it now Diego offhandedly
mentioned that he didn't have anything
to wear cosplay-wise other than an Ash
Williams costume we were already using
for another video go watch it and ask if
he could borrow my cool dread replica
helmet as a pseudo cosplay obviously
Jacob and I being the cosplay fiends we
are couldn't stand for that and elected
to just build the entire costume for him
in one day using stuff we got at the
grocery store the morning before the
convention stick around after this break
to find out how it went
special thanks to raycon for sponsoring
us once again raycon earbuds are
disrupting the electronics Industry by
making great sound for half the price of
other premium audio Brands raycon
earbuds charge enough for 32 hours of
battery life with up to eight hours of
uninterrupted play time letting you
seamlessly connect with Bluetooth
devices they're compact comfortable and
portable with easy to use functions for
toggling between three customizable
sound profiles noise isolation and
awareness mode they come in a variety of
customizable colors patterns and fits
for extra comfort and no dangling wires
or stems co-founded by Ray J raycons are
hit with celebrities like Snoop Dogg and
J.R Smith who I've definitely heard of
because he was in the nuggets for a
little while I've been enjoying them
while taking them on summer trips with
my friends like Denver Fan Expo or the
Stanley Hotel click the link in the
description box or go to buy raycon.com
forward slash Godzilla Mendoza to get 15
off your raycon purchase now back to the
video
Judge Dredd is a cool character that
doesn't get brought up enough on this
channel no it's not copaganda it's a
satire about how over policing makes
crime substantially worse in this
completely jaded future society and
Joseph Durrett is a weirdo that has no
social life and arrest people for
completely ridiculous and benign things
also sometimes he fights a ghost that
was ripped off to be an Overexposed
Batman villain his costume in the comics
is really garish and bright and loud and
arguably hard as [__] to move your arms
in but that's kind of the fun of it
homelander stole his shoulder pads given
that we had an already extremely limited
timetable to pull off a decent dread
look we couldn't go for something quite
so extravagant and opted instead for a
mix between the more grounded Carl Urban
body armor look in the original Comic
version my dad got this helmet for me
for Christmas from a seller on Etsy and
it's really high quality it fits well
it's comfortable and it's made of a
sturdy material that looks good on
camera it's exactly how I imagine a real
judge helmet would feel given that it's
one of the more comfortable sci-fi
helmets out there believe me I've tried
on a lot of sci-fi helmets Mike Judge
over here is practically just wearing a
hard hat and sunglasses and it makes
sense how you could wear it all day
without taking it off because it doesn't
really impede your ability to do
anything although I'll say that the
weird cross-section of red dipping into
your peripheral as a range choice but
eventually you don't even notice it what
purpose does that entire design element
serve doesn't matter looks cool you
nitpicky [__] so yeah I cheated in
the most complex single component of the
build was purchased from someone who
assuredly has better equipment and
skills than I do but that's part of
Cosplay if you can't build it buy it if
you can't buy it make it out of
cardboard that took a lot of the
difficulty out so we could figure out
the rest of the design okay now go like
this and we get him a pirate hat and
he'll say Yar it's driving me nuts
yeah seeing as how it was based on the
2011 dread armor it was handy that Diego
brought this black BMX chest guard to
recycle when we made the aliens video he
just peeled the stickers off and it was
good to go
having some spare components lying
around like this is good because
something nondescript like that can be
used for a variety of cosplays if you
paint it yellow you can be Cyrax you can
glue foam to it and have it be the basis
of some Spartan mjolnar armor or you can
use it to get shot at with paintballs
but your friends that aren't actually
your friends they just like hurting you
and you should really start talking to
new people because this isn't healthy
for anyone involved given that this
armor was a nice and versatile piece to
use for various suits I didn't want to
make any alterations to it that couldn't
be undone so it could be recycled by
Diego again should he find another
cosplay it could work for so everything
attached to it had to be easily
detachable which added to the difficulty
of the cosplay along with the bad time
limit that's why I decided to use this
velcro tape I found at Walmart it's
sticky on one side and velcro e on the
other side we also found these painter
knee pads that would be like the perfect
size and shape for some dread stuff if
they were gold judges need comfortable
knee pads because cops suck dick ooh
edgy actually on the list of punch lines
I could have made there that's like the
seventh edgiest I've mellowed out in my
old age I found two gray hairs the other
day I'm only 25. I wonder if it's just a
vitamin deficiency or if it's stress
related or both
I also had a weird dream that same day
where a nuclear reactor melted down and
burned all my skin and it was peeling
off and sticking to my charred clothes
in a glowing desert I think I'm on the
verge of a mental breakdown please hit
the Bell icon so you get notifications
when I upload because God knows the sub
box and I are not speaking terms lately
be sure to also join the patreon because
we've got some cool exclusive videos on
there every once in a while and it's
really cheap oh yeah anyway we found
this car floor mat at the grocery store
too and realized it would make a great
way for creating some detailed makeshift
armor we chopped it up with an X-Acto
Knife as always make sure to cut toward
yourself so the adrenaline and fear of
being cut makes you more precise with
the blade stabbed my thumb and it
prevented me from Comfortably eating
chicken wings for several days this
section here was perfect for that
classic Judge Dread asymmetrical
shoulder pad and evoke the same look
while also being a small enough size
that it didn't look too big compared to
the other shoulder I painted the knee
pad with some glossy Plasti Dip spray to
rubberize the foam and give the gold
layer a more shiny metallic look it
makes the material stronger but it also
primes it for paint more effectively so
it doesn't look like foam at first
glance while he worked on that I was
hard at work masking off this ten dollar
laser gun we got at the convention
earlier that day so he could turn it
into a cool lawgiver pistol like in the
movies
he was so meticulous about the masking
that he even used a layer of toothpaste
to mask the parts that he couldn't
easily get tape around but wanted to
remain silver I painted that shoulder
pad and then busted out the craft foam
to do the opposite side the movie
version of this shoulder pad retains the
golden eagle imagery but keeps it
rounded off and flush with his arm
instead of a big and blocky thingy I
wanted to find a middle ground that was
a similar shape to the movie version but
it had the same Dimension and silliness
of the original so I opted to use a knee
pad as a base and build off of it using
the pattern from the movie but having
the wings of the bird going past the
edges and wrapping around more of his
shoulder if we had more time to make
this than in a single night it would
have been more layered and detailed but
I had to settle for something simple
enough to make under a time crunch but
also evoke the right look after that I
created this goofy little block of foam
to add to the front of the pistol to
capture more of the law Giver aesthetic
from The Dread movie I went to the Star
Wars School of sci-fi design which means
adding random dimensional Square panels
on scenery that has no specified
function
then you can stab some screws into your
foam crafted metal stuff so it looks
more believable when those catch the
light and are visible as real metal my
foam crafting was a little messy much
like me as a person but Jacob was able
to bring it all together with some
really clever painting he did a layer of
dry brushing with black paint on the
light areas and silver on the darker
components to weather the gun the gloves
and the armor that element really
brought out the grit and grime we were
looking for and made everything just to
look a little more real okay so I just
shoot the gold in this cup yeah and and
set it down on the cardboard because one
time I I did this uh in a red Solo cup
look at that [__]
melted the bottom of the plastic cup wow
I don't know what it did it's not hot
see see what
how does that happen I don't know the
plastic doesn't like the chemicals all
right next coat with that cool car floor
mat all painted up we cut some small
slits into it and used zip ties to
fasten it to the chest armor through a
few holes for ventilation that were
already there again we wanted all of
this to be reversible if he needed that
armor for something else later on that
and the golden foam armor editions
really pulled the Judge Dread look
together with a semi-futuristic
semi-gotty patriotic look Diego's own
personal contribution to the suit was
this custom-made badge that he bought on
Etsy with his name engraved on it that
really was the cherry on top that made
the whole thing look a little more
official than the sum of its parts
so I velcroed that onto the chest and he
was ready to go we went to the
convention and Diego made it a point to
keep his helmet on the entire damn time
and he got a lot of really positive
responses and was stopped for pictures
so many times we lost count look at that
smile that was seventy dollars well
spent or whatever next time we'll do
Deadpool look forward to that goobers I
don't have a judge helmet but have a
judge Sleepy Eye mask
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign